pas besoin d'aller au bout du monde pour
constater les conséquences des
changements climatiques sur les humains
c'est comme les radars
il faut semer la terreur il suffit
d'aller au bout du québec sur la basse
côte nord
ici tout le monde parle d hiver qui ne
sont plus les mêmes
c'est pas normal moi je pense qu'on va
tarder si ça continue demain on vote
avec la glace qui fond c'est un mode de
vie qui pourraient disparaître
si on n'est plus capables d'aller dans
nos territoires qu'est ce que va devenir
l'avenir de notre pain des prisonniers
chez soi c'est ce que moi je trouve
qu'on est la basse-côte-nord comment
sous la route 138 se termine environ
5000 personnes vivent dans une dizaine
de communautés long de la côte
l'été un traversier ravitaille les
communautés et permet aux résidents de
se déplacer l'hiver un mythique sentiers
de motoneige la route blanche relie les
villages mais post année la glace n'est
pas assez solide pour permettre la
circulation se recharge tout notre sol
d'un d'être capable de voyager entre
dévidage chili vers la route plage ce
n'occupe humain c'est notre route
on est avec randy jones le maire de gros
mécatina qui regroupe les communautés de
la tabatière et de bd moutons il nous
invite à faire le tour du village en
motoneige gars on voit un voisin qui se
posent au mois de février dans la biche
soucier se peut que ce que ça veut dire
mais c'est loin d'être beau et les
goélands sont pas là par hasard
les scientifiques affirment que jamais
ils n'ont vu aussi peu de glace sur le
saint laurent
c'est une conséquence directe du
réchauffement de la planète sur la basse
côte nord
ça veut dire que la banquise côtières ne
s'est pas formé les b non plus n'ont pas
gelé et quand la motoneige ou l'euro de
la voiture
c'est un gros problème
c'est plus dangereux déjà rempli de
chancy des fonds sur la glace il va
penser on a eu trois ou quatre accidents
sur la baston des gens qui se sont noyés
on était les premiers pour savoir qu'un
que la pêche aux mots vue est en train
de disparaître
on a essayé de dire ceux aux hautes
autorités et l'eau c'est la même chose
avec la température la température
change énormément
si quelque chose est parfaite
bientôt on aura pinard plus divers et
des gens vont venir ici pour l'épargné
il se sait pas nécessairement quelque
chose qu'on veut tout
il crut
un terrain tu
saucier la mer en train de frapper par
la drh au large
une vraie musique
moi ça me donne des frissons
[Musique]
pour s'occuper l'hiver davies m et son
père ivn coupe du bois de chauffage
la majorité du bois et donner à leurs
voisins sur la côte c'est pas un cliché
dire que les gens s'entraident
[Musique]
cette année les lacs ont gelé traita à
la fin février
ça complique l'opération et quand tu
tchoffo bois c'est pas banal mais
d'aider d'autres soucis c'est le
propriétaire d'une auberge pour
l'entrepreneur la route blanche qui
n'ouvre pas c'est un désastre financier
[Musique]
strang de route blanche à la route
blanche si l'unique chemin entre les
villages cet hiver la seule option est
de prendre l'avion ou l'hélicoptère et
ils sont peu nombreux à vouloir payer
près de 500 $ pour un trajet de 30 km
vous rêvez pas il ya bien quatre box
d'un garage de ivn
la communauté de la tabatière aînés de
la chasse aux phoques à l'époque au fond
des wendel grave on travaillait la peau
et nourrissait les chiens de traîneau
avec la viande le phoque est fondamental
dans l'histoire de basse côte nord
et ce conseil sipa la place par les
brigitte bardot la chasse aux phoques
est toujours pratiquée c'est une source
de protéines fraîche dans une région les
arrivages de nourriture se compte en
semaines on le capture au filet à
l'automne une chasse sur la banquise à
la fin de l'hiver
mais cette année c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué
[Musique]
en plus parce qu'on peut faire qu'est-ce
qu'on veut pas beaucoup de règles à ma
petite scène on a la paix
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as l'impression que tous
les chiens tous les changements qu'on
voit dans le temps dans la météo un
climat est ce que ça va influencer votre
vos habitudes de vie selon toi je pense
que oui si cet univers comme cette année
enfin c'est correct pour aller dessus
mais là on a perdu quoi dur moi j'ai
l'impression que que toi tu dis comme
même si ça change je veux rester je vais
m'adapter
[Musique]
quid du nom
c'est impossible d'aller sur la basse
côte sans parler du prolongement de la
route 138
depuis les années soixante dix des
policiers promettent au nord côtiers de
les relier par une route au reste du
québec
pour plusieurs les enjeux climatiques ne
font qu'augmenter la nécessité d'une
route pour sortir les communautés
d'isolement québec et ottawa ont
d'ailleurs annoncé 400 millions de
dollars l'an dernier pour relier
certaines communautés entre elles
il n'y a pas cinquante solutions il ne
puisses s'appelle la bonne
il va insérer un dieu que c'est ces
pauvres vivant mais la route le monsieur
john je vous entends parler la liberté
d'une culture propre vous avez pas peur
que la route menace non non on va on est
menacé comme ses doigts c'est peut-être
la seule façon de nous sauver
parce que sinon je jouais pas que tout
le monde reste et ça coûte trop cher
pour rester ça c'est la réalité
on reste ici pour une brève
c'est pô le petit père des dettes d'être
capable d'aller à la chasse
de se promener dans le bourg
si on peut pas faire ce matin droit
d'être casté isolé
si on a pas de route c'est le début de
la fin de nouveau
des et nous amène en train d'analyser
des avions pour transporter décroche et
du manger de baies et bullet tout le
monde sur la planète prennent ça pour
acquis main pour un village sur la
basse-côte-nord quand keita trosman sein
de bateaux au dos ni de la bio ça
deviendra maire problème
unamen shipu c'est l'une des deux
communautés innues de la basse côte nord
pour comprendre l'importance de la
motoneige ici il suffit de regarder le
stationnement des élèves à l'école du
village
on a été invité par alexis lalo a passé
une journée en forêt rapidement on doit
changer d'itinéraire
on est à l'embouchure de la rivière
rouge côté habituellement et 7 l'on
pourrait traverser dirais que c'est plus
possible parce qu'à l'impôt prix c'est
dangereux de penser tu vois la glaire et
noir doivent mettre en place des
surprises qu'on peut raconter
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est très
dangereux
quelqu'un peut tomber à l'eau peut avoir
l'hypothermie à peu faire un acte i
dames est décédée par des villes
tout peut arriver il sait très précaire
comme conditions hivernales
puis je souhaite que qui ait pas
d'accident et je sors
m
bon on va commencer à fait chez motown
c'était assez la teste pas ce qu'on fait
et par la pilaterie démarre au fait
d'avoir des surprises aux pressions ont
fait d'emprunt blanc pour alexis pour
plusieurs autres membres de la
communauté
les changements climatiques représentent
un danger pour leurs cultures qui se
transmet à travers le territoire perdre
leur route ancestrales c'est un peu
perdre leur histoire c'est très inquiète
à cause entre nos habitudes de vie vont
être perturbés dans les airs dans les
années à venir
c'est plus comme les oeuvres d'art il
faut se méfier dans la terrasse à notre
savoir nous connaissons nos savoirs
traditionnels ont pu transmettre à la
nouvelle génération y a quand même un
danger
la transmission s'est fait beaucoup de
façon visuelle c'est pas écrit mais
c'est plus notre vision et la course que
du foot foot et tu expliques en même
temps que tu vas le faire
nous autres on a survécu à cause de la
nature de on parcourait nos territoires
nos rivières et si demain qu'on a
survécu notre peuple et weight il voit
tu être condamnée a vu dans les réserves
ce sont me pose quelques questions
savoir mettre en danger la pérennité de
2000 tradition
[Musique]
mais avez-vous espoir quand même
je souhaite juste faire
[Musique]
la société qui va décider du sort de la
planète
on trouve un autre monde
montrer qu on se soucie seulement de
l'aspect économique
pas de l'aspect humain social
on
on risque d'avoir toute notre culture
d'héritage qu'on a je suis peut-être
pour d'un bain des gens c
c'est fox nécessairement important ben
pour nous autres c'est vraiment
important c'est notre chez nous c'est
notre façon de vivre
[Musique]
le reste du québec
va perdre une richesse qui savaient même
pas exister
c'est une espèce de pêcher marten
d'avoir quelque chose si beau d'un tacot
c'est même pour ça existe
jakub smrz team qui ne voit pas avec la
même
pas besoin de regarder loin regarder ça
[Musique]
c'est du jem à vue